[Music]
in this morning's eye on money we are
looking at a growing problem for
shoppers nationwide price increases and
a shortage of goods in stores in a
gallup poll 60 percent of adults said
they could not get a product that they
wanted earlier this summer because of
supply problems
cbs news business analyst jill
schlesinger joins us jill good morning
to you what is going on here we've got a
few things that are going on at once
first of all it's all about shipping
shipping containers because of the
pandemic have ended up in the wrong
places so they're sitting empty in
places where there's no product to fill
them and where we need them in ports
where we have a lot of supply they're
not there so that's one big problem the
second issue is we really made some
decisions during the heat of the
pandemic that are still rippling out
today so big electronics and chip makers
they said hey you know what we're going
to do we're going to focus our energy on
consumer electronics that's what seemed
that everybody wanted and then all of a
sudden everyone wanted a car and there
are no semiconductor chips for cars
finally in this economy if we go back
two years many companies said we want
very low inventories that makes us more
profitable and that has really come to
bite many firms in the touch
so here's a serious question do people
really seriously no joke right now in
summer need to start holiday shopping
all right i know it's okay
no joe gayle says no i just want to say
that knows nothing
the problem is that there are going to
be shortages on whatever is most popular
that happens every holiday season right
so it's electronics and it's toys and
it's holiday apparel and it's home
furnishings this year it's going to be
more pronounced now the big suppliers
like the hasbros and the mattels they
say we've got plenty of product the
problem is consumers guess what you're
going to end up paying 5 to 10 percent
more this holiday season so i would
start monitoring prices online right now
tony i've got your christmas list it's
new tie new tie you know not a fan oh
it's cold come on
i like this top but he loves you yeah i
love her already
spring projects people are talking about
spring projects already do you think
people need to stock up on stuff like i
saw something the other day about a
lumber shortage already this is really a
problem because what we've seen is a lot
of the process of building a home takes
a long time anyway but when you add on
the supply issues it's intense so we
have seen shortages of lumber and we
have seen shortages of blue stone and
everything that goes into a house house
price materials are up by 19
but if you're thinking about trying to
get a jump on this be careful lumber
prices were up over 1500 bucks
back in the spring now down under 400 so
don't try to time the market one area
where you should maybe think about
ordering right now appliances there it
is hard to get an appliance if you know
you're going to need appliances get on
it and be flexible about your pricing
and also about the finishes i'm still
upset about the shortage of computer
chips for cars because my son just
turned 17. i'm looking to buy him one um
but also there was a different type of
shortage at my house for chips during
the corner i thought you're upset about
the shortage of kindness over taking
shots at my i don't like to tie either
cool with that yeah i'm cool with that
jill thank you so much